[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
welcome to this week's
bonehead of the week breakdown i guess
this is the first one we've done isn't
it yeah this is the first one yeah this
is the first one but uh we we put a poll
up on twitter just to give everyone
context and we were like ah let's pick
out three [ __ ] boneheads you know and
put it up there see who votes and gets
the so today is the very first breakdown
video breakdown
streaming breakdown
of the bone end of the week poll
and uh let's see who we had on the uh
list so we had uh mr kyle rittenhouse
tucker carlson and then alex jones of
course uh for some context and why don't
you give us the context of these uh and
then we'll go surf twitter and see some
of the videos so obviously kyle
rittenhouse for obvious reasons
uh that little [ __ ]
uh tucker carlson for amplifying uh that
little [ __ ] and doing a a uh
documentary you know let's very loosely
put that it was a propaganda machine
video for uh kyle rittenhouse and then
alex jones uh i'm not guilty uh i i i'm
not gonna show up for the subpoena for
the january 6 committee
so of course uh when we go to the polls
and maybe we should just uh maybe we
should go to the poll and just show
everybody what um
what what the the results were here let
me let me bring it up here on
the tweety tweets
and uh we can we can play the uh
let's see there it is
okay so
let's bring it up here
here's the here's the poll result
um for bone end of the week
who's the bone of the week comment below
with your reason of course we had kyle
rittenhouse at the top and then uh
tucker carlson and then alex jones so he
had our results of
28.3 percent where kyle rittenhouse
55.7 with the winner and tucker garlson
and then alex jones came into 16 with
1247 votes
but let's play the animated version of
who wins
[Music]
[Applause]
so congratulations to
tucker carlson yeah for uh for the uh
bone end of the week there i like our
graphic with the kids yay you know it's
it's trying a little bit of a
a positive you know to a very yeah
shitty group of people well i mean uh
obviously we want to congratulate them
for being the [ __ ] bone of the week
uh i do want to play this uh you sent
this to me i think yeah paulie the
paulie
polly takes yeah
so he says so i fixed the tucker carlson
kyle rittenhouse interview you're
welcome and he tagged tucker carlson so
let's let's give paulie a shout out here
let me um
let me give him some copy uh so that he
knows he was on the uh
he knows he was on the bonehead
breakdown maybe that's what we call this
thing is the bonehead breakdown
breakdown yeah let's see
[ __ ]
there we go all right so gave him credit
so let's let's watch his uh his uh
his video here we'll put it we'll put it
big here
what did you make of the president
united states calling you a white
supremacist
mr president if i could say one thing to
you i would urge you to go back and
watch the trial
and understand the facts before you make
a statement
what did you make of the president of
states calling you a white supremacist
so that's uh i could say one thing to
you that's fantastic to go back yeah
he fixed it
he was able to just capture it so
beautifully right um speaking of uh
polyteks and fixing it did you see cause
of course i'm sure next week we'll have
uh lauren bobo berber bobert the pew pew
the pew pew barbie as uh on the list of
course we have we have a little surprise
this week for here in a bit but uh
uh
he fixed that video too it's kind of the
same clan type yeah did you see maybe
we'll play that one if if you guys vote
for lauren bobert next week maybe we'll
play that as a as a prize
for the winner yeah he he did a good job
of covering that one as well
yes yes that one was very good that was
very good uh let's see what else is in
the uh because he had the of course here
is the uh it looks like the actual
interview here
um let's see is that is that is that
what that is
yeah that's the actual it's a clip yeah
so i think this is uh him him giving
remarks about lynnwood oh okay yeah
let's let's let's watch this this is uh
this should be fantastic here let's
let's hear what he has to say how long
were you there i was in jail for 87 days
not long enough this goes this follows
in with lynn wood who
lynn wood
was raising money on my behalf and he
held me in jail for 87 days
disrespecting he held him in jail put me
on media what the [ __ ] i should never
have done when she said oh you're gonna
go talk to the washington post which was
not a good idea along with john pierce
right there listen if you're listening
to anything linwood says yeah or john
pierce or that right for that matter but
also this is one of those moments where
it's like i'm the victim right he his
you know he says lynn wood and john
pierce told me to go to talk to these
different publications and they they
kept me in jail regardless if they kept
you in jail which seems very odd um
but just know it's like
yeah you were part of the grift they
made money on you oh i mean he's gonna
continue to be part of the griff don't
you think oh i mean
you watch you see you see em and trump
doing the thumbs up [ __ ] photo that's
all a griff too yeah and that trump
doesn't give a [ __ ] about him or his
family yeah
yeah and
at the core of it he's like oh you know
i should have never been there long you
know they were making money off me they
kept me in jail this and that and it's
like you're not the victim here right
one again let's just clarify
you had an illegal firearm that you
brought to a protest
that your friend bought for you right
and you shot and you killed two people
and injured another person you know and
it's like
uh you did something illegal so
you went to jail
and like you said it wasn't long enough
but for him to go like oh no i'm i'm the
victim and i'm not a white supremacist
and i'm not this and i'm not that and
you know it's like shut the [ __ ] up kid
okay right you were in the wrong
and you had to pay the consequence for
doing so you know
i i well i mean it the fact that he
claims that lynn would keep him in jail
like what do you talk in jesus christ
well and and again if you're listening
anything that [ __ ] squirrel turd
linwood he's none of you in a squirrel
turd this guy if you're listening to
anything that he says you are a [ __ ]
bonehead bonehead bone i don't know i
don't know
i don't know if you you have you been
following up recently but i guess you
know kyle rittenhouse made some remarks
about how lynnwood was
i forget the exact wording but basically
alluded the fact that he is uh kind of
crazy you know he's like out there
and the q crowd the q anon people are
not having it no yeah they're pissed off
well i mean i mean that's that's that's
that's the good part about all this
craziness is eventually it's all going
to collide they're all on the same page
you know when trump was really you know
he was in power and he could tweet and
all that kind of stuff but now they're
they're kind of losing their mojo
right so
his lawyer was also gonna against all
this [ __ ] too
you know yeah like like the linwood and
the documentary which we'll get back to
but um you know he was kind of against
all this stuff too let's go to our last
contestant alex jones let's see what uh
what we got over there
um because i know
i know alex had a video
yeah he uh he was very much again felt
like he was going to be the victim seems
like there's a pattern within this party
that it's always
i'm not the one at fault it's someone
else at fault and i'm the target and i'm
the victim so as a result i'm not going
to take ownership or responsibility for
the thing that i actually did wrong and
why i mean do you expect anything less
from these [ __ ] people alex alex
jones will tell him you know straight
from the horse's mouth you know in the
ivermectin he took he'll tell us
well let's let's uh let's see if we can
find this is the clip that we're looking
for here right
because this is this is him describing
um the january 16. now he's been in the
news other than just this january 6
being subpoenaed he also gets he's also
going to get sued and possibly have to
play pay monetary damages to the parents
of uh that's yeah yeah it's the uh for
the defamation lawsuit that again he was
claiming i'm he's like i'm the victim i
turn in my financial stuff and they said
it was
uh it was
uh what did they say it was it was
fraudulent or faked and he's like i
don't even know how you could do that
you know anything did you do didn't you
do another one of these field wood
outside videos for that too why not
complain
it's it's alex jones's field of dreams
is what we'll call it yeah
why the [ __ ] you look at this video you
see it looks like he's on the edge of a
golf course like he just did like the
back nine right now he's giving a little
video with the caddy holding the camera
you know right right and he was he and i
mean and it says banned video does all
his videos say that kind of [ __ ] like
bank like
i also well that might be uh i'd have to
look it up but is it a platform or
something i don't know but it says
banned video you see that versus now of
course ron ron tweeted this and he says
uh alex jones today says
uh it says he doesn't want to spend the
rest of his life in prison so in other
words he's done something to spend the
rest of his life in prison so what he's
gonna do is he's gonna plea the fifth so
that way he might but let's let's listen
into his own dumb ass words here
um what he has to say let's play thing
to the committee which isn't even true i
wouldn't lie no and then they will have
the fbi yeah the justice department
indict me for lying to congress they
sure will yeah so that's a crime they've
been asking why other people weren't
declaring the fifth
i'm probably going to declare the fifth
not because i've done anything wrong but
yeah
political criminals it's funny because
he's like the fbi definitely is going to
get me for lying to congress because if
i didn't believe the fifth and i say
what i want to say to keep my ass out of
trouble i'll definitely get held
you know
in contempt or or perjury and it'll be
criminal and
you know what he's just he's he is
projecting what he
you know he's afraid of doing so he's
like as a
i'm innocent and i'm not going to say
anything where they're going to try and
trick me up because i'm actually guilty
so as a result i'm going to plead the
fifth which makes you seem more guilty
again if you're innocent and you did
nothing wrong and you know you can prove
that you did nothing wrong then there's
no reason to plead the fifth
to make tim right because i mean
pleading the fifth is almost this you
know self-incrimination it makes you
look more guilty now you can keep
playing it off and say like oh i played
the fifth uh you know i'm going against
the
the bureaucracy of this committee and
i'm gonna fight it by not speaking you
know and it's like
chill the [ __ ] out man we all know you
did something right good news of you
from january 6 you're bragging about it
you're talking about it and now you're
saying you're not going to say [ __ ]
because you're actually being held
accountable and being subpoenaed
and you think you can get away with it
well i mean they were bragging they were
bragging about organizing with these
with these [ __ ] you know the
insurrectionists the people that
actually went there and tore down the
windows and went into
to
look what looked like was trying to kill
the vice president and other members of
congress i mean
and they were you know not not just
cheering them on there was organization
of it and i think that's where the proof
of the select committee is going to come
in and where these [ __ ] are going to
you know get torn down let's listen to
what the rest of this [ __ ] meathead
has to say here that have an axe to
grind and have been bragging everywhere
they want to put me in prison okay i'm
47 years old yep don't have anything
any of those issues going to i'm a
person a family man and i don't intend
on spending the rest of my life in
prison no sir don't want to have that
happen and so
who who the [ __ ] runs around like you
know what i want to do you know what i
want to do i want to spend the rest of
my life in prison that's what i want to
do like that's i would love to go to a
federal prison camp for the rest of my
life also what people do he also said in
the video he's like you know i did
nothing wrong i'm not gonna go whatever
and it's like listen if you never
wanna go to jail then don't do anything
wrong
right and of course here he is yeah here
he is so here's the segment on january
6th yep so let's let's give credit for
this video here uh hang on let me let me
get my copy back here uh we'll give
credit for this and then uh we'll play
this and then we'll go on to the the
the dishonorable mention and then we'll
go on to the the bonehead of the week
the man of the hour yeah uh
our winner and we'll talk about uh i
guess the documentary probably but let's
let's listen to this
this nonsense here this has got 1.6
million views yeah this one uh kimmel
originally posted this so
let's um then the white house told me
three days before
we're gonna have you lead the march the
secret service before trump finishes 30
minutes before so he's saying here we're
gonna have you
like as in him right lead the march and
he's saying the secret service he's even
bringing in trump there like yeah like
if this is his attempt at saying like
he's not responsible because other
people told me to do it right it goes
back to like well if someone told you to
jump off a dribble or off a bridge would
you do it right like well it depends on
how much reads in their pocket right
really you know i mean it also depends
on you know how deep into the cult they
are right right and
i mean they are still waiting in dallas
for for jfk junior he's gonna show up
he's gonna show up well somewhere i'm
confident i'm confident i you know what
i i wish there would be like a really
really good
impersonator like a really good oh like
spot on just show up down there bring in
a podium yeah and then and then have
like have like uh a jfk not just junior
but jfk impersonator and him kind of
look like he just climbed out of his
grave or something yeah yeah yeah you
know maybe
maybe have the motorcade go through
jfk junior gets picked up and drives
away what's wrong with these people
oh he's [ __ ] let's listen to what
this will lead you to a point yeah take
you out of the front row yep and leads
you to the place where they want you to
start the march and trump will tell
people go and i'm gonna meet you at the
capitol that's exactly what happened
three days before that's exactly what
happened he led because if you there's
other videos of him out there like
leading up to the catalan then when he
kind of gets to where he knows oh [ __ ]
this is
what we were planning might come true he
kind of him and um ali alexander is that
his name
yeah
they kind of back off because they were
with each other like during the whole
time right and and uh ollie alexander is
the one who
said uh mo brooks and andy biggs and uh
paul gosar were helping him plan this
right he was the one that went on to the
instagram live right and admitted it
out of
hubris i don't even know but like you
know it was well surely that'll be part
of the evidence in this for sure yeah
it's uh i mean like he openly admitted
it and i think from what i understand
there was some there was some
conversation that was happening and he
wanted to prove
proof himself in some way
validate himself i don't know exactly
what the rationale was but i know it all
happened on instagram and then it was
shortly thereafter deleted by him
right uh but at this point it's
already been documented saved and
shared all over the internet
so let's let's get back to the
man of the hour but before we do that
you have an honorable mention you'd like
to uh yes a dishonorable mention that's
that's right dishonored yeah i didn't i
didn't man that you know honorable
discipline what whatever suits your
fancy here we'll call the dishonorable
mention for the bonehead of the week
breakdown but i think every week we'll
have uh someone who wasn't originally in
the running right now maybe mostly or
some weeks someone won't come up but i
think that
within this party you know uh we'll
always have many people to pluck them
well and i'm sure these these
dishonorable mentions will be
dishonorable enough to end up in the
next week's poll oh yeah sure there will
be doubling down and they will end up
being one of the contestants
uh in the following week i'm positive
i'm sure this dinner dishonorable
mention this week we'll probably find
yourself in the poll next week right
well uh so let's pull that up uh and you
can explain go ahead and explain the
dishonorable mention here yeah
dishonorable mention for this week is
lauren bobert
miss bobo herself um
miss uh i tweet uh nancy pelosi's
location on twitter
um
[Music]
she was doing what seemed to be some
sort of thanksgiving dinner
i joked about it how it was in the back
of a cracker barrel right uh and she was
doing
these videos keep coming out and i want
to give uh credit to patriotics because
they've been releasing
a handful if not more of these clips
where she's
making
uh islamophobic islamophobic jokes
uh and she's making
you're referring to when she calls it
like a suicide bomber and the jihad
jihad squad and the no backpack and all
this stuff she made jokes uh homophobic
jokes against uh pete boudijes and about
chester which i even in the in the same
speech in the same little okay so so
this is this is like a really bad
stand-up routine yeah it's the worst
open mic night i've ever seen because
i've watched i've watched a few clips
and um i caught the clip where she's
talking about mar-a-lago i caught the
clip where she's obviously calling
um
other members of congress which i think
is very important here suicide bombers
and jihad squad if she was just some
stupid some stupid [ __ ] who was going
around doing really [ __ ] shitty stand
up and saying this type of stuff you
know i i don't know that it has i mean
it's it's it's noteworthy like look how
[ __ ] crazy this is getting that the
supporters of donald trump but this she
is a [ __ ] member of congress yeah
like this is not this is not congress
yes
she's not a former member of commerce
she's not someone who has voted out
which she's likely to get uh uh jerry
mandered out anyways in colorado but but
that's just kind of below i mean also
the people that far from uh uh her her
district hate her there's been multiple
uh accounts and
interviews with people who are like she
doesn't do her job she's more
interested
in
the
the fame of lauren beauberg i mean yeah
i mean
that was the whole point that's the
whole point of lauren bovich so maybe
she'll end up on the poll next week so
everyone should listen in and check out
the uh at
tony michael's pod page that's where the
poll will be and of course we'll retweet
it and send it around at this this this
we put out a poll what was this is the
second one we've done yeah and it got
kind of popular so we figured we'd do a
little breakdown here uh and and we'll
keep doing this as long as as long as
you guys watch the [ __ ] so keep watching
keep interacting with the poll and also
if you haven't noticed we have bonehead
of the week.com you can go on there and
you can actually enter in
who your favorite idiot is to put on the
list and maybe they'll end up uh also if
we get enough entries maybe they'll end
up on the bonehead of of the week poll
but uh so so obviously tucker carl's in
one here 55.7 so he's our
he's our man of the hour as it were you
know it is one of those things where
tucker carlson you know could
could win
every week if he was in the poll by
himself well if you look at some of
these comments um
[ __ ] tucker he interviewed that murderer
that disrespected our president of
course uh again this is uh um let me get
my copy here so we give credit for
reading some of these comments
um but this is going to be a reoccurring
thing with uh tucker i think where he's
gonna end up on the bonehead a lot oh
for sure a lot a lot all right okay so
thank you better world for that and for
anyone who's watching or listening uh
definitely you know when you when you
vote leave a comment because yeah yeah
and we're going to read these out and
we're going right
yeah read them out loud we'll try to
read some of them out loud the other
thing too is um you can also you know
put uh
who your favorite was so we kind of know
who you voted for
because the poll really doesn't tell us
who voted for what it just it just gives
us a number of votes and then the
percentage right uh mayo one of our
favorites says this was a hard one so we
get that a lot of like where's the all
the above i can't choose between these
three and this one was really difficult
like this one was
it was hard you know for
for both of us you know we very much be
like yeah all three of these people are
[ __ ] shitty and they are bonehead of
the week however
for this to be an actual competition
it needs to have one winner right
because every week theoretically
all of the above could win and then you
know well yeah we could have 50 people
on the go right yeah well minus jules
says aldi but i like her i like her her
gif is it a gift or is it a gif which
one is it it's a gift but this is i say
gif i say gif yeah and obama says gif
it's done it's been decided let's see
have we got any more good ones here
we can't read them all because we don't
have time to read all of them but we'll
see if we can find another one
uh
let's see
it's like a rouette you guys commented a
lot on this i really this is this is
this is why we're gonna keep doing this
um
always tucker for me yeah
always i saw another one that was
tuckums will always win this award let's
let's go back and uh let's let's go back
and read that one i think it's right
yeah uh
scroll
up
down i don't know which way you're going
here yeah well i'm i'm scrolling off
round and round all the way around yeah
uh
yeah the consensus was the consensus was
in the comments if you guys haven't
looked at it
is that um
tucker is always going to be this yeah
at at all times it's never going to quit
with this guy and really he's almost
like you know he's like an all-time qb
you know he's just always right here we
can we can definitely count on this
[ __ ] megan the bonehead of the
week list a lot yeah a lot a lot a lot
so let's let's go see if we can find
um
the oh that's not what i want
let's go see if we can find the um
the video of the documentary
um because that's that's one reason why
we put him on here obviously
interviewing
uh
written house but the documentary let's
see if we can find this uh yeah the
propaganda piece uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
when they when they actually left the
courthouse
this is the interview this is which i do
want to i i do want to point something
out here that you know some people have
talked about but didn't get a lot of
coverage is the fact that so there was a
whole msnbc
freelancer whatever that
situation was right the guy was like oh
i'm a freelancer and i uh he got stopped
right and then uh
judge bruce schroeder said i am now
banning
msnbc from the courtroom right you're
talking about the one that they kind of
accused of following the bus right
exactly like like they were going to
take pictures
i don't want to point out like you know
i don't i don't see msnbc uh willingly
putting someone in the contempt of court
in a fine
for a photo especially if that photo is
going to be published or that thing is
going to be published it's a direct link
to say you guys violated
the rule that i put forward right like
it just feels like a weird thing to be
like i'm gonna break this rule
and i'm gonna show this evidence
and then claim that i didn't break the
rule right
right and uh the thing that a lot of
people pointed out or some people
pointed out and didn't get a lot of
coverage
but it was the fact that msnbc gets
called up by judge bruce schroeder about
being banned right uh this alleged
incident that happened with the
freelancer msnbc can no longer be
in the courtroom
but throughout this whole trial
we find out that tucker has special
access
to another floor
where uh where kyle rittenhouse is he's
getting interviewed
these things are getting documented
by which needed approval from judge
bruce schroeder so for them to say
in other way in other words in other
words it's not being done without his
knowledge he knows yes
he he knows that on us on a floor in a
room with kyle rittenhouse there's a
documentary crew and tucker carlson that
are there to
get this which which is against his
lawyer's wishes apparently that's what
his lawyer claimed yeah is that it was
against his wishes so here here is
patria takes and i gave him credit here
uh tucker carlson made this documentary
about kyle rittenhouse it releases in
december um of course this is uh from
november 19th
but this is i think they dropped this
like almost immediately as he's walking
out of the courthouse yeah they got the
footage from the courthouse with a smile
and dropped it and then boom okay so
let's let's uh let's play this piece of
trash here
that's what we do is uh play trash
because that's all they are is [ __ ]
cheap you up at night there is [ __ ]
truck once you finally do get to sleep
you're dreaming oh he can't sleep at
night isn't that so sad [ __ ] hold
sweat yeah
you had dreams about what happened
every single night
oh my god every single night it's it's
quite scary actually because the dreams
feel so real
and they're gonna
[Music]
like what if i wasn't alive or what if i
ain't what if he didn't bring a gun
[Music]
but it's that type of [ __ ] that
they're like oh what if i didn't you
know what if i uh what if it never
happened right he's like oh well what if
i wasn't attacked by rosenbaum or
whatever it's like regardless of these
people and backgrounds or whatever
maybe if you never brought
an assault rifle
to a protest
then no one would have gotten shot right
and i feel like that's a big thing and
the prosecution definitely did a good
job of like did not do a good job of
proving or getting to that point
but i think at the end of it he's like
oh what is somebody taking my gun and i
for sure believe that if this person
took my gun they would have killed me
it's like well if you never had the gun
no one would have attacked you you would
have never been the person provoking the
incident you wouldn't know well i mean i
mean i think i think i think the
consensus is throughout the country that
he caused this thing it wasn't like yeah
yeah it wasn't it wasn't like he was
sucked into this situation he he did all
the things that he needed to do to go
there and do the [ __ ] he did and at the
end of the day he wasn't held
accountable for it at all now i think
karma's going to hold him accountable
just like it held george zimmerman
account whether you believe in karma or
not i don't really but but i think i
think the fact that that it is obvious
that this kid is going to go along with
these people grifting in his name he is
completely [ __ ] here like this guy
this guy's gonna end up somewhere else
with a [ __ ] weapon um he's and
they're gonna be watching him like a
[ __ ] hawk i mean this isn't gonna go
well for kyle rittenhouse i mean he's
gonna be a pariah uh once these people
have
chewed him up and spit him out so
you know uh and as far as tucker carlson
that's why he's the bone end of the week
because he's [ __ ] tucker carlson and
and because he just can't help but
grifting off this type of [ __ ]
garbage he just can't help but he's the
one who is helping to push this message
of kyle's the victim and he was not the
perpetrator and he deserves all of our
sympathy and he's not a murderer he's
just a self-defense victim yeah shut the
[ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ]
up shut the [ __ ] up right that's it
he's the absolute worst like if you went
in the dictionary and you looked up
worst the worst the absolute worst you
would find the [ __ ] face of tucker
carl so you're saying in the dictionary
where it says bonehead yeah i mean right
there that's right there if we looked
him up in the dictionary this week you
would see his face probably that little
picture right there like in the middle
confused the confusion
whenever someone's talking
it's always going to be that confused
tucker dumb ass face should we play the
should we play the the video one more
time of him winning
should we do that oh yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so thank you tucker carlson
for being our bonehead of the week or
[ __ ] you for being our bonus yeah any
way you look at it and next week so guys
don't forget uh you can go to bonehead
of the week.com you can put in uh who
you want your favorite idiot to be if
they might show up on the bonehead of
the week poll we're gonna put these
polls out i think on wednesday and you
vote two or three days and then uh we
declare a winner and we'll make the
little video and then we'll keep doing
this if you guys keep watching the
breakdown
of why these people ended up on the bone
of the week we wanted to explain it to
you on video
on a stream
and this will air on youtube twitter
twitch just like all the rest of the
stuff uh i think we've got it set for
sunday
8 o'clock central 9 eastern right and
then what we're then we're doing okay
good and then maybe maybe we'll make
that a thing where it airs that time or
we'll pick another time and we'll tweet
it out and let you know so thanks for
joining us for the very first
the very first of the week bonehead
bonehead of the week
we'll see you next week and there
is bound to be plenty of [ __ ]
boneheads
[Music]
[Applause]
bye